if someone were to show you these album
covers or these posters even if you'd
never heard of the band's featured you'd
probably be able to guess what kind of
music they play this style has become
synonymous with the psychedelic 60s but
these abstract forms and Curly barely
legible lettering they weren't created
in the 1960s it came from a celebrated
art movement one that started almost a
century earlier in the late 18-hundreds
new technology electrical power
telephones cars was changing the way the
world worked and the way it looked and
some people especially artists living
through this technological revolution
were not so into all the new industry to
be blunt they thought it was ugly out of
this conflict a new global artistic
movement was born one that went by many
different names like the secessionists
in Austria and the Glasgow school in
Scotland but you might know it as Art
Nouveau which literally means new art in
French its creators wanted to make art
that reflected the vibrancy of city life
they used flat decorative patterns
feminine figures and organic and plant
motifs often stylized with fluid
abstract forms and they applied this new
visual language to just about everything
from architecture to paintings to
textiles and beyond because they believe
that aesthetics should go hand in hand
with utility and no object was too
mundane to be beautiful like this
entrance to the Paris subway or these
posters by Alphonse Mucha advertising
champagne and biscuits which are just as
much about being beautiful as they are
about conveying information okay back to
the hippies like the late 1800s the
1960s were a time of cultural people the
Vietnam struggle those are
in the US the epicenter of this change
was San Francisco where hundreds of
thousands of young people descended upon
the city for things like protests and
drum circles and of course concerts lots
and lots of concerts particularly dance
concerts featuring trippy psychedelic
music from bands like Jefferson Airplane
and the Grateful Dead and there was one
major way to get people to come to your
concert a good poster back then these
now iconic bands were just starting out
playing back-to-back shows at venues
like the Fillmore and the Avalon and to
advertise this new generation of hippie
bands those venues knew that plain
typeface and a grayscale photo just
wasn't going to cut it so they
commissioned work from a small group of
artists who developed a brand new
formula for concert posters one then
pulled from a variety of established
design traditions comic books surrealism
and of course Art Nouveau by the mid 60s
Art Nouveau was already experiencing a
bit of a resurgence especially when it
came to textiles dynamic floral designs
were a natural fit for the hippie
aesthetic which is probably why in 1965
a museum just outside of San Francisco
launched this exhibit legend says this
is where some of those designers were
first exposed to Art Nouveau one
designer West Wilson told Time magazine
that he admired their idea of really
putting it out there and when they
started making new concert posters these
designers took those Art Nouveau staples
and turned the dial up
our TiVo is famous for its feminine
figures most often nude with flowing
hair and a come-hither glance a style
those psychedelic designers clearly
picked up on look at the way these
posters are covered edge to edge with
detailed two-dimensional illustrations
particularly flowers and abstract curves
and also peacocks
that's an Art Nouveau thing too they
loved peacocks
and sometimes psychedelic designers
would use images pulled directly from an
Art Nouveau poster but always with a
radically different color palette
instead of Art Nouveau soft pastels
these artists opted for intense high
contrast colors said to make your eyes
vibrate a reference to the visual
experiences of an LSD tripper and that
curly cloudy barely legible font it
started here on a 1902 poster by
Austrian designer
Alfred roller in the 60s artists adapted
his bold dynamic typeface and pushed it
even further softening its lines and
obscuring its edges making it nearly
illegible which served a purpose it was
meant to grab your attention and keep
you interested at least her as long as
it took to figure out what the poster
was trying to tell you the result was a
ton of posters that look like Art
Nouveau on acid as the music of San
Francisco spread throughout the world so
did the aesthetic in part because
posters are easy to own and reproduce
and collect with fans sometimes tearing
them down immediately after they were
put up the artists behind them even
became celebrities in their own right a
few of them got their own spread in Life
Magazine the posters they made their
vibrating colors and winding lines
capture the energy of the 1960s just
like the Art Nouveau ones represent the
late 1800s and while these two time
periods don't near each other perfectly
both movements were able to create
something that captured the feeling of a
changing world and their art reflected
that
[Music]